[Music]
we all remember this moment Melania
Trump gifting Michelle Obama a Tiffany's
box during the 2017 inauguration now the
former first lady is confirming what was
inside it was a lovely frame there's all
this protocol so they tell you that
you're gonna do this they're gonna stand
here and never before do you get this
gift so I'm sort of like okay what am I
supposed to do with this gift everyone
cleared out and no one would come and
take the box and I'm thinking do take
the picture with Wow Michelle didn't
know what to do in that moment she
admits her hubby helped her out my
husband say that it see he grabbed the
box and took it back inside fitting the
pair always seems to have each other's
back in 2015 Michelle spilled the et
about how they plan to overcome empty
nest syndrome together Rock and I we
spend most weekends we're staring at
each other cuz somebody is at a
basketball game somebody's at a dance
somebody's sleeping over we're the last
people our kids want to be with so I
think they're conditioning us for that
empty nest syndrome I don't know what
we're gonna do I got to get him some
more hobbies
[Laughter]
you